Food Heels Podcast Episode 295.
President Nixon declared the war on cancer there was one in 21 Americans with a diagnosed
with cancer back at that time.
Now it's at a rate of 1.2.5 Americans will be diagnosed with cancer at their lifetime.
Holistic Voice presents the Food Heels Podcast with your hosts, Alison Melody and Suzy Hardy
joining the Food Heels Nation and learning the secrets to go from feeling unwell to healing
yourself.
Warning, side effects of this podcast may include increased health and vitality, thoughts
of living longer and increase in sexual activity, feelings of joy, cravings for kale and
quinoa and a spike in tender matches.
In rare cases, people have experienced a strong desire to put down the benign jerrys, get
off the couch and take a walk outside.
If you experience any of these symptoms, tell your Facebook friends immediately.
Alright, welcome Food Heels Nation.
Thanks for joining us.
I'm Alison Melody.
When Nixon declared the war on cancer in 1971, it was said that one in 21 Americans would
be diagnosed with cancer in their lifetimes.
Cut to the early 2000s, this is when my parents were dealing with cancer, it was said that one
out of four people would be diagnosed with cancer in their lifetimes.
And according to today's guest, as of 2020, it is now one in 2.5 people will be diagnosed
with cancer in their lifetimes.
I'm shocked.
I mean, this statistic is showing that the current healthcare model when it comes to cancer
is not working.
And that's why I'm so glad to have today's guest Dr. Kevin Connors here on the show to
break down what is working.
After graduating from Northwestern Health Sciences University with his doctorate, Dr.
Connors has spent most of his professional life through the Connors Clinic finding an alternative
way to treat cancer and autoimmune diseases.
So today he will explain how his multifactorial method has turned into the number one, number
one natural cancer treatment center in the country.
So I'm very excited for this episode, tell your friends, send it to any of your loved ones
who need to hear this.
Let's get right into it next up my episode with Dr. Connors.
Please welcome to today's guest, Dr. Kevin Connors.
Hello, really?
How are you?
I'm really, really well.
I'm very excited to hear about your journey and your story and have you on today.
Oh, great.
Yeah, so you have been practicing functional medicine since the 80s.
Can you take us back and tell us how you got into it?
Sure.
Well, I graduated as a chiropractor back in 1986.
So this is a vintage baby.
So but I graduated as a connezologist, nutritionist type of chiropractor.
So I was basically doing functional medicine before that term came out.
So seeing a lot of autoimmune thyroid patients, adrenal fatigue issues, dealing with that kind
of stuff, a chiropractic as well, did that for a number of years, ended up getting a little
feeling maybe.
I wouldn't say burned out, but feeling like God had something different for me.
I just never, I always felt unsettled.
So I sold my practice and went into, ended up going into full-time ministry and we've served
as missionaries down in Mexico, my wife and kids and I, and eventually came back at
90, seven, and went back into practice again, and then that's when the kind of God showed
up, and she'll be what I was really supposed to do, which would work with cancer patients
in particular.
Yes, and that is so close to my heart because, you know, I lost both of my parents to cancer
by the time I was 25 years old.
Yeah, and I just saw how Western medicine had failed them.
And so I went on a mission to discover alternative ways to heal, and that's when, you know, I discovered
all of the things that we now know and that you now are helping people with.
So I would love to go into cancer a little bit and talk about what you found and what are
some of the things that we can do to fight and treat the cause instead of just the band-aid
approach.
Right.
That's amazing how many cancers that, even the standard medical procedure is to look
for the cause, but it's always post-mortem.
It's always after a person passed away, if there's a study going on, and that's unfortunate
because standard medicine, standard ecology does not look at the cause at all with cancers.
And though I will say in their defense that if you treat the cause of a person's cancer,
if you were able to be as, you know, definitive as possible, it do so.
It's not necessarily going to kill the cancer cells that are already growing, but it can help
decrease metastasis, and that's really four out of five cancer deaths.
That's really what is the cause of the death is the metastasis.
So if you could help decrease rate of metastasis or the possible metastasis at all, you're going
to help a patient in a lot of time.
Absolutely.
And so what are some things that you take your patients through to do that?
We look at a patient as holistically as we possibly can.
So you have to look at what brought the person up to that point.
There are certainly nutritional things that we need to change, dietary things that we need
to change, and then environmental things, because most of the time we're testing a person.
So there's multiple causes of cancer, first of all, there's never just one thing or
rarely just one thing.
And many of them are environmental.
That's what I believe at least one of the reasons why our rate of cancer has increased so dramatically
over the last 50 years, good as when I think President Nixon declared the war on cancer, there
was what in 21 Americans would have been diagnosed with cancer back at that time.
Now it's at a rate of what in 2.5 Americans would be diagnosed with cancer at their lifetime.
And the argument is, well people are living longer, well no, it's not that there be diagnosed
with cancer at 65, we're getting children diagnosed with cancer, we're getting so many more
younger people in their teens and 20s and 30s diagnosed with cancer that was just never seen
before.
Yeah.
And I didn't even realize it was 1 in 2.5, the last stat that I had heard, which I thought
maybe was a few years ago, was 1 in 4, so it sounds like it's even gotten worse since I was
getting into this.
And that's a scary fact and the environmental factor, I'm so glad you bring that up because
I also believe that cancer is multifactorial because they're not only are we sometimes creating
cancer on our own bodies with our lifestyle choices but sometimes the people who are doing
everything supposedly right and eating their greens and everything like that are still being
affected and so that's when it can be the environmental factors that are really coming into play.
So I would love to hear some of the treatments that you help people do to deal with this.
I totally agree with you, we have had patients come to us say, how could this possibly be
me?
I've been eating organic for 25 years, we'd ever spray our lawn with pesticides, you know, we're
so very careful in our exposure to chemicals, how could this possibly be?
But we live in a world that is so toxic.
If you're not doing all those things on that list, your chance of not being sick is pretty
much as zero.
So you have to try to prevent it as many ways as you can, helping your environment, diet,
et cetera, and still, you know, you can move to a mug top and maybe that'd be worse because
the air is going to be bitter, I don't know, but it's hard getting away from that.
Right.
So we have to get ready to the question of what do we do to treat it?
So number one, we have to share our little legal caveat that we can't treat cancer.
We're not ecologists, but how do we take care of a person that has a diagnosis of cancer?
And that we have to be as holistic as possible, too.
So be careful, I always warn patients, be careful what you see on the internet, I always try
to respond to these little partial factoids that people post on Facebook of, you know,
some of them that kills the cancer in 98% of cases, well, those things are so true.
So there's nothing that's going to kill cancer in 90% or 60% of patients.
It's lay in trouble.
It's going to help cancer patients in a small percentage of people, protocell will help cancer
patients in a small percentage of people.
And that's what we try to do.
So we take them, everybody is an individual, so we can have a set of twins, and we can have
a set of twins in a small percentage of people in a small percentage of people in a small percentage of people.
Everybody is so individual here when you're trying to find what is going to work best for that person,
you have to go with the way to be able to test that person to see what we're working for.
And that's what we try to do.
Everybody is an individual, so we can have a set of twins that have breast cancer,
the same breasts, both ER positive and HER2 positive.
And when we test them, it might be a different diet, might be a different nutraceutical approach,
it might be a different even cause, even if it wasn't the same cause, it might be a different way
to pull that out of their body.
So everybody has to be treated as individual, that's our one rule and our office.
There are, we get patients, patients that call us and say, what's your protocol for prostate cancer?
We don't have a protocol for it, we develop a protocol around you, and you as an individual.
I'm so glad you're bringing this up because I could not agree more.
We talk about this all the time on the show, especially when it comes to diet,
because it feels like everyone wants to know the perfect diet and whatever is trending,
used to be those South Beach diets and there was slim fast diets and there's always something right now,
there's a lot of gluten free and I'm personally vegan, but that's what works for me,
it's not, doesn't necessarily work for everyone, but it's finding out what works for you and that's
really what functional medicine testing is all about, because you can discover your own food allergies,
your own nutritional deficiencies, and create the perfect diet for you.
So is that this similar approach that you take to figure out the treatment protocol?
The exact same approach we take, we talk about specific diets for cancer,
what you're really looking for, cancer is it's rapidly replicating cells,
so there needs to be a fuel source for that.
So you think, well, everybody should be off sugar, well, yes, because sugar feeds right into glycolysis,
which is where you produce energy, and that's where energy can be produced for cancer cells.
But then when you, okay, we take out sugar, we should, nobody should be sugar ready,
how, whether you have cancer or not, then what's the best diet? Should I be juicing?
Should I be vegan? Should I do a keto diet? That's a real big thing right now, several books were written
about keto diets and cancer, and though it can be very beneficial for some cancers, what bothers
me about those books is that when you start slapping that label on every single person as cancer,
because then it just falls into, this is just not true again. So a ketogenic diet, you know, is
high in fat, which can feed some cancers. Unfortunately, a lot of ketogenic diets have animal proteins
as a source of their proteins, which can be a major feeder of some people with cancer
that are fed through methionine and glutamine pathways. They have to be completely or as vegan as
possible. And ketogenic diets tend to be high in dairy, which you never want to give dairy to a
cancer patient. It just raises IDF1 levels to high and will stimulate growth. So you've got to be
careful of fat diets. You want to be tested. We do specific testing in our office for what
can be feeding them, fuel source for that person's cancer. Everybody's a little bit different,
and we could do genetic testing to look at that too. And then we can also look at things that are
maybe stimulated, autoimmune responses, so that's specific food testing as well.
And so can you take us through some of the, if we're changing our diets based on our functional
medicine testing or genes testing and the things that you're doing? What are some things that,
what are some alternative medicine practices that you're recommending to people based on when
you figure out how to treat them? So we look at diet, what we just discussed, what's the best diet
for that patient based on what is that cancer, what's seeking for a fuel source, and that can change
over time. Number two, we look at what are specific nutraceuticals, supplements, herbs, etc.
That will be a quote-unquote cancer killer for that person, a natural chemotherapy for that person.
There are dozens and dozens of cancer killer type supplements that have, each one of them can have
1,000 people testimonials that this quote-unquote cured their cancer using SCACT.
But just for every person that has been helped by SCACT, there's probably, you know,
five that it didn't work for. And you could say that with each of the natural cancer killer
supplements out there. That's why I can get a bad name, an alternative cancer treatment can get
a bad name when you start putting these wrong expectations on specific nutraceuticals.
So you want to be as specific what's going to be best for that person, for diet, you want to be as
specific what's going to be best for that person for their nutritional, their nutraceutical,
what supplements you're going to have that on. And then there's some supplements that you don't
want cancer patients to be on. You don't necessarily want to be stimulating. You might have
a conural function with a cancer patient that's very fatty right now, pushing the nerve to pathway
and such. It might not be the best approach for a cancer patient because cancer cells are very highly
metabolic and they will suck up that nutrition and it will actually help them grow. So there's
certain things you don't want to do with the cancer patient that you would do with a cardio patient
or autoimmune patient or a lying patient. So it's a little bit some things that you want to
know on how to treat a cancer patient a little bit differently. And then there's different
dumb specific therapies that can be extremely beneficial for cancer patients. We use one of them with
all of our cancer patients and that's the RIF machine RIF, who was started by Royal RIF back of the
30. So we use that with all our cancer patients. But there's other therapies that we use as well,
hybrids. There be a PEMF, you do where others that could be extremely beneficial for cancer patients
as well. Yes, I did an interview with someone and his wife swore by the hypothermia for her and it
literally saved her life. And you know what I find interesting, you mentioned the RIF machine
and that's something I think you said from the 30s. And then I know in your blog, you talk about the
1899 Merck manual and how the remedies are natural and food based. How did we get here when there was
so much good information that has just disappeared? This is what they used to do, right?
Well, it's unfortunate that what they used to do worked but had limitations, right?
Praise God, the invention of discovery of antibiotics, right? That saved millions of people's
lives in wartime and epidemic time, but it has limitations. Unfortunately, we threw out all the herbs
in the natural approaches for our use of modern medications that could be patented by pharmaceutical
companies knowing full well that there's limitations to both. Now, why can't we just vary both of them
together? Well, you and I know they're really sad, answer to that, oil burning, greed and money
and control. And that's a very sad thing. But that's where podcasts like yours are so important,
because it empowers people to take control back of their health care decisions so that they can
start going, oh, maybe I will do some people therapy, but I'm going to use the RIF and I'm going to
change my diet and I'm going to, I'm going to, you know, use some specific nutrition as well.
Are you going to be wise about this and not just turn over by all my health care choices to this
doctor because I don't want to take responsibility. Unfortunately, you know, how many percent is
probably 80 percent of the people are still into that category. But we try to educate people to
take control back of their life. They don't have to just surrender their braid at the door of the
hospital where they walk in and they can marry the two systems by seeking out other help or using
multiple doctors. I could not agree more. You know, I always tell people that my mission is to
inspire people to take their health into their own hands and stop outsourcing their health to doctors,
right? Because that's unfortunately, that's what my parents did and we didn't know any better. So
we were in North Carolina, small town and what the word of the doctor was literally the word of
God to my family. We didn't know of any other way and what they were telling us to do was the only
option. And when I brought up things, I was like a young with my mom, I was like, you know, 20.
So I'm like, young and there's no YouTube videos at this point. So I had no outlet to discover
alternative knowledge or anything like that. And I would bring up things like, doesn't matter what
they eat. And literally, the young college was like, it does not matter. It has nothing to do with
this. And I was like, okay, great. And my mom would take a bunch of supplements because she knew
about alternative medicine. She would take all these supplements and he would go, I mean, do what you
want, but they're not going to do anything. You know, it's sad that it continues today. It just got
off the fold 30 minutes ago with a patient who she told me that her oncologist said, if you want to
eat cake every day, just go ahead and eat cake. Oh my god. So say, come on people. Yeah. I just
talked to another patient yesterday who he said he was so upset because he asked his oncologist
about juicy. And the oncologist said, I don't know anything about that. So I wouldn't recommend that.
So it's like how could he was so upset that how could these people who claim to treat cancer for
a liby not know about any other approach? And it's hard to have an answer for that really. Because to
me, there really is no excuse. Now, I did my trade either. I graduated as a chiropractor. But
when I started seeing cancer patients 21 or so years ago, you know, God just kept sending me these
cancer patients like, well, if I mess it this up, you know, I take grave responsibility to take
you these patients on. So I went back to school and got a degree in integrative cancer therapy
as an AMA fellowship. So they're all medical doctors in my training. And it was a really an
eye-opener for me years ago to have them say, oh my gosh, you're a chiropractor. It's so great. I
wish I would have gone that route because you could use all this. And like, what do you mean? And they
said, oh, we're just learning this for our families because we can't use this in our practice.
Oh my gosh. I guess I was always in private practice so I could, you know, do what I thought was
the best interest of the patient at all time. And they said, they can't. They can't even recommend
physical oils to their patients or still get in trouble. It's so wrong. It's so backwards.
It's very sad. So if someone is listening right now, Dr. Conner's, what can they do? You know, I know
you have a great book, stop fighting cancer and start treating the cause, which was your premier
book on cancer care. I know you have many books, which we will talk about as well, but they can get
your book. How can they work with you? What can they start doing on their own? Can you give us some
really practical advice? Sure. It can always work with us. You can call us and set up a case review. We
call additional consultation with me. But I realize not everybody could work with us. So we try to
give our way as much information as possible. We have like you multiple podcasts, probably 400 and so
YouTube videos trying to teach people as much as possible so that they can be empowered to do this
themselves. We give away our book for free on our website. All our books are free on our website.
I write multiple blogs every week. We have at least 400 pages of those. There's lots of
doctors like me and people like you that are giving away this information all the time. In one sense,
there's no excuse for not knowing how to do some level of self care. But in the same sense,
I know a lot of people, they need that handhold. They need to be, you know, get greater tested and
get more adept. And that's who we're here for. And there's other clinics like us that are doing
the same thing. Try to help people the best way possible. The best maybe first starts
go to our website, look at our blogs, look at our videos, all the information that we try to provide
for your charge for people. And if you'd like to speak with me for sure, contact our office to do so.
Okay, so it's Conner'sClinic.com. And that's where they can get in touch with you. And what is your
YouTube? Our YouTube is, I think it's just if you just search Dr. Kevin Conner's CEO and ERS,
you'll find our YouTube channel there as well. You can link to our YouTube through our website as
well. So all those links are on there, our Facebook page too, we're always putting stuff on Facebook as
well. So through our website is probably the easiest way to get to all those other venues. And I know
that you have done so much more work. And I really wanted to focus on cancer because it's close to
my heart. And I know a lot of people, like you said, one and two point five are dealing with it. So
I'm glad that we covered this, but you've also done a lot of work with Lyme disease and autoimmune
conditions. You have a number of books on them, beating chronic, you have an article as well,
beating chronic Lyme, the three phases of Lyme, Lyme brain help my body is killing me, which is
about Lyme and autoimmune diseases. Can you take us through some of that? Why are people getting these
autoimmune conditions? Are they multi-fectorial, just like cancer? You know, give us the goods.
Well, they are multi-fectorial, everything is, but the biggest reason why we have such, it's almost
like you could look at your little kids or grandkids and it's not, will they get an autoimmune disease?
Which autoimmune disease will they get? Unfortunately, that's just the truth. The damage that we are
doing constantly to our guts are testing a wall barrier is probably the number one reason why autoimmune
disease has gone through the roof. And even if you're not taking antibiotics or exposed to antibiotics
or keeping your kids off of those as much as possible, it's because of our foods and the GMOs and our
foods and the chemicals in our foods that are damaged in the gut wall, even if you're trying to eat
organic. So you could eat a perfect diet and raise your kids in this perfect environment. The
chemicals that they're exposed to that are damaged that gut border is the number one cause for autoimmune
disease. To mention, okay, hot topic there, vaccination that is damaging, you know, and the
braid and increased inflammation in the gut in the braid. And that's really what's leading to
autoimmune disorders. You start to develop antibodies to self-tissue. But Dr. Conner's the internet
told me that GMOs and vaccines were safe. Yeah, yeah. Well, the internet, if there was one,
at the time, would have told you back in the 1950s that smoky to safe too. Right, exactly.
There is wisdom in a multitude of counselors and you have to seek those counselors, you know,
it's so funny when you get bashed like I do on the internet for speaking up against vaccinations
or GMOs, I have zero financial bias to say those things. Right, right. It only hurts me to say those
things from a financial standpoint. I lose patience by taking a strong stance against things
like that. And you lose credibility because you have these trolls that are bashing you constantly
giving you bad Google reviews and saying nasty things on Facebook about you who don't think about
you and you know that they're just a troll. Right. But you just have to believe in something and stand
for once right. No better what? Even though it might not be popular in this day and age. Now there's
a lot more educated people out there. There was 10 years ago when I 20 years ago when you first started
saying these kind of things. Praise God for that that people are getting their eyes opened up to the
truth and some of this stuff. But still it's just people want to believe that the medical establishment
to it never do anything to harm you and the defense of the average general practitioner that's
out there they're not trying to harm anybody. But why learn anything? Do and cutting edge if
you can't use it number one and it could hurt your golden handcuffs that you're tied to in your
position at work. So they just stay with the status go and it's basically produced by the pharmaceutical
industry telling them exactly what lied to the whole time. It's literally the biggest tragedy
and I tried for so long to shot it from the rooftops and then I just decided to shut up and talk only
positively about health and host this podcast to have people you know smarter than me such as yourself
to explain it in greater detail and and give it to the people who really want to hear what we all
have to say which is why I started food heels. But I'm really appreciative of you and what you do
and you know what you said earlier I had chills just being like exactly we don't have a financial
incentive right everyone else does so who are you going to listen to the ones with the financial
incentive and that to keep us sick right exactly that's exactly it. So let's take us through auto
immune auto immune a little bit. I know you said it is multifactorial just like you said cancer was
what are some things that we can do my mom had multiple sclerosis before she had cancer some
very familiar and you know it was the same thing there were no natural cures available or offered to her
it was just drug after drug after drug it was pain killers with side effects and then there be
another pill for the side effects and I just watched her weather away until she literally got cancer
and you know passed away very quickly. Well in all honesty the cause of the auto immune disease may
have actually also been the cause of the cancer. I don't know. We'll cause a lot of you disease
that people will go along I thought it was genetic. Well that's just not true. So an auto immune
disease is when your immune system is attacking self-tissue or better definition is when your
immune one side of your immune system your B cells make antibodies against some cells in your body
maybe your thyroid gland or in the case of multiple sclerosis it's starting to make antibodies against
your light of your violent sheath cells so that your immune system is attacking it you have
de-biolidation take you place or sporadic clacket on that violent sheath cells trying to protect
so then you go well why would my immune system do that? Well your immune system isn't supposed to
attack self-tissue. Right. Well there had to have been something there for the immune system to
recognize as an enemy either you know a toxin or a biotoxin like bacteria or virus or fungus or
live disease of some kind or some co-infection that your immune system saw as an enemy
in lodged a T cell response a TH1 response against it was not able to kill it probably went on
for months and months and then finally lodged as a B cell response or a TH2 response it creates
antibodies against the cell line there which the violent sheath cells and then you end up with
symptoms of MS and then you get a CT scanner MRI and you have sporadic clacket and then you get
the diagnosis of MS MS is the disease it's just the signs that they see at a CT and MRI that say
you have MS there's multiple causes of MS whether it is that initially that bacteria or it could be
lime it could be mercury toxicity from mercury fillings or goodness we say vaccinations that
your immune system tried to kill wasn't able to kill created antibodies to try to then destroy
that tissue line in the thought of well it's better to lose that tissue line that this person
to lose their life due to this poison and you know you have antibodies to self tissue and now every
time you fire an immune response for any reason you will attack that which you have antibodies against
first and if you have antibodies against self tissue every time you fire an immune response you're
going to be attacking that self tissue so that's what used to have just built up destruction and over time
it could lead to all sorts of problems and even death but what type of auto immune disease you have
what type of antibodies were created because of what was there in the first place. Thank you for
breaking that down so clearly I really appreciate it and going back to one thing you said this has
always stayed with me both of my parents had metal melts what was leaking into their bodies for 20 30 40
I don't know how long you know how many years they both had fillings in the back of their mouth
I remember gold and silver what was leaking into their gut at all times what was off-gassing into
their mouth you know and I can't say it was the cause of MS or the cause of cancer but we know
that these things are multifactorial and I definitely think they were contributing factor so when I
discovered this my dad was actually still alive and just before he died was when I was starting to get
all my fillings removed and I haven't had a filling sense or anything like that but it's terrifying
because you can be doing everything right look just like we said earlier eating all the right things
living a healthy holistic life meditating on a mountain that's not too high in the bad air
but then you could be every single day being exposed to your own toxins in your mouth and that's scary
and so if you have a second to go into that what should we do if we're like oh my gosh I have fillings
and they're 10 years old and they're not using good stuff back then I don't even know if they're
using that stuff now necessarily well we won't know for another 10 years probably exactly god
so yeah you have silver fillings burkery fillings probably the worst what do I do should I get them
all removed I've looked at people's balls and they have above so full of fillings that literally
they'd have to just pull out the teeth because you know they're just well you know wild around that
baller that it's how are you gonna get that out so it becomes a very difficult decision
by approach as a functional medicine doctor has been if the person's healthy you know that suffering
from an autoimmune disease right now that diagnosed with cancer and they're then that's probably the
best time to take out those fillings and have them removed but you have to factor in if the person
isn't under care for somebody who knows how to help deal with that we need if I'm gonna have a
burkery fillings removed you have to go to a natural dentist who's gonna use a burkery vacuum
who's gonna use a rubber dam who's going to do everything possible to prevent the off-gassing
breathing in and off-gassing as they're removing that filling or you swallowing in that burkery
and then also dealing with the gum around there that already absorbs the burkery trying to
clean that out and then also going to a functional medicine doctor that's gonna also put you on
a key later to help pull out any you're still gonna spill it into the blood you pull out a key
later to get it out pull it up that person a binder to make sure that's bound in the gut so that
they're not reabsorbing that so there's multiple things that you want to do you don't want to just go
and have your cavities removed or your fillings removed you want to do it correctly or you could
add up a much worse situation than before you started but then the primary is if the person's
already ill can they even handle probably those burkery fillings and your bad dental work so you
need to get some wisdom in there and really look at each case separately yes and thank you for
mentioning that this is what happened to me literally I don't remember how many years ago it was
now but when I got those fillings removed I never got tested by functional medicine to see if it
was still in the blood nothing like that and 10 years later I go to my first functional medicine
test and there's mercury in my blood and just because the fillings were gone didn't mean it wasn't still
in my body and so I had to do the chelation right so it this stuff lasts and I'm not trying to
scare anyone but do exactly what Dr. Conner has just said if you are healthy enough to get them
removed then there's some maintenance you got to do and make sure it's out of your system
yeah well the half life of mercury is probably about 15 million years so I don't think it's
cold anywhere fast my god you're being able to hold up your body all right let's go into prevention
and treatment so we can stop scaring everyone but I like that we're you know we're just telling the truth
and because I've lived this I know it's real and I'm trying to make sure everyone understands you know
what what we can all deal to avoid some of this and if we are already you know suffering
what we can do so what's what are some good preventative measures for autoimmune and what are some
treatments I know it is multifactorial and we're gonna change the diet and things like that but what
are some things that everyone can do the way we deal with any autoimmune disease you have to start
with a gut so you want to heal the gut border I know a lot there's a lot of products out there that
work out of the gut but you if you don't deal with antibodies to food so if you have an autoimmune
disease that you have had a damaged gut for any length of time you those that lose border that
wide border of the gut wall the damaged cells are gonna allow proteins of different foods to cross
into the bloodstream that should never have crossed in it should have been broken down specifically
to amino acids and then being able to cross so when you have those large peptides those portions
of proteins that cross into the bloodstream that should never be in the bloodstream the only
cross because that damaged gut border you're gonna develop antibodies to those peptides that is the
negative cycle that is created that keeps a person in an autoimmune state so they might clean up
their diet they're gonna go up gluten and go up dairy and they're gonna eat a vegan diet and
they're gonna take a bunch of different really good supplements gut healing supplements and heal their
gut well even going on a gluten free diet you know there's your maybe eating foods with the flowers with
tapioca starch in it you know that you weren't used to before and as that didn't get broken down
fully still through your damaged gut you've developed antibodies to tapioca starch down
so even though you're trying to do a lot of right things every time you eat gluten free flour with
tapioca starch as an example you're firing this immune response and this immune response is like a
fire in the gut and it's damaging gut cells again and it's just never what why can't I get better
scenario from this person to hear all the time I'm doing all these things right I'm gonna eat gluten
free and dairy free for five years and vegan for eight years and I've been on all these products
how come I can get better well you're gonna do support in-depth testing on antibody tested and see
you know wow you're reacting to cooked carrots a weird thing like that because of that all started with
that damage got doesn't mean you can't eat cooked carrots again in six months but you've got to stay
off when you've got it decreased that immune response you know look for everything that's
fire-rated immune response everything that's doing damage remove that heel and then you could slowly
introduce those things back to your diet yes thank you for breaking that down I really appreciate it
your primary focus which we haven't gotten to yet because I really wanted to cover those
they're very close to my heart but it's really genetics and I know that you mentioned it earlier
and I know a lot of people who literally go well I am bound to get cancer because so-and-so in my
family did or I'm bound to get this or that and I that's simply not true in my opinion so what's
the deal with genetics well there's there are about anywhere between three to five percent of cancers
that are truly have a genetic time or direct cause we should say I think there's there can be
genetic ties to a lot of people's cancer but let me explain because these are all epigenetic ties
meaning that there's things that you could do to change that for the environmental food choice lifestyle
choice perspective so there are in your cells if a cell is dead and D&A is damaged somehow
usually do let's take to a toxin or a biotoxin that gets in that cell and now that cell goes into
a state of rapid replication that's what cancer is so cancer is something affecting the D&A
replication cycle of additionally simply one cell so let's go back to our mercury toxicity
picture so had all this mercury in my mouth had it removed tested myself 10 years later my blood test
shows my I'm high in mercury what the hey I had this removed 10 years ago well mercury has a half
life of 15 million years and it's still circulated by blood it stays in my cells so it could in the cell
it could damage the D&A and cause the cell to go into rapid replication now most of the time it
doesn't otherwise we'd all have cancer but it can do that and that could cause the cell to go into
rapid replication create another cell that's in rapid replication that's the definition of cancer
and truth be told this does happen to all of us maybe on a weekly basis but in each cell we have
specific genes that are called tuber suppressor genes so if the cell does erodeously go into rapid
replication these tuber suppressor genes should kick in and cause the cell to die we'll get into the
process of that but it kills the cell that's the purpose of a tuber suppressor gene
that happens to us on a regular basis so if you've never been diagnosed with cancer the truth is
you've had cancer multiple times your body has used its failsafe methods like this there's others
but this is one of them and it killed that cell so you never got a diagnosis of cancer
however we can have genetic defects in tuber suppressor genes understand also that tuber suppressor
genes are governed by specific metabolic processes and the need for specific nutrients to help
stimulate or up-regulate tuber suppressor genes helps prevent cancer that's why okay we'll use an
example of curcumin anti-inflammatory product of turmeric is a strong tuber suppressor up-regulator
in almost every study that's out there shows it these are all peer-reviewed studies not done by
natural doctors tuberic curcumin helps up-regulate p53 helps up-regulate most tuber suppressor systems
so if I do have defects on my tuber suppressor genes there's multiple different tuber suppressor
genes but if I had defects on my p53 tuber suppressor gene and I was taking curcumin
that I would have my p53 though because of the defects it may not be working as well as if it
didn't have defects if I was taking a nutrient that would help up-regulate it then it would work better
so knowing your genetics before you have cancer could help could help you not to get cancer because
oh look at these defects you have on this cell line it'd be really good if because of the studies
that are out there that if you got on this supplementary started eat more Indian foods with
to a record it that would help prevent that for you or in another person because of these defects you
have in your detoxification pathways you don't detox large chemicals very well because look at all
these defects on your pond one pathway that's another genetic pathway so it would be who viewed to
maybe support that pathway because this nutrient this nutrient this nutrient has been proven to help
up-regulate that pond one pathway so this would be a good thing for you to be on because you're a
slow detoxer of these chemicals also at least we're not to use pesticides on your pond also at least
more to eat organic so you could help prevent disease by looking at a person's genetics you could
take a person that is sick look at their genetics and it can give you clues to maybe why and then to
make adjustments to help support those pathways you're not treating the G defect but you're you're using
wisdom through looking at that those G defects and it can give you clues to some things that you may
want to do to change in your lifestyle that could help prevent or help you deal with whatever disease
process you have going on. So what I'm hearing is essentially just like everything we've been talking
today it's extremely individualized and you won't know the right protocol for you unless you get these
tests done to find out exactly what you need and what you don't. I'm simplifying for myself and for
any other listeners and another simplified statement I would I know there's more to it but would you
agree or disagree with the statement that I hear a lot and I've said on the show that genetics when it
comes to chronic diseases and things like this genetics load the gun but lifestyle is what really
pulls the trigger. Well absolutely and this we really want to even get a little deeper it gets kind
of scary because it is the lifestyle exposure to toxins and chemicals and such that can actually
cause genetic defects. So the reason why I have the genetic defects that I have most of the time
is because I inherited them from my mother and father. But I can have genetic defects because
I worked in a paint factory for 10 years and actually was the person mixing the chemicals with my
hands and didn't care about exposure because I got a bake a living and that could have caused genetic
defects and now then I have a babies after that I'm passing them on to the next generation.
So the really sad thing what we could say all the chemicals that we're exposed to in the pesticides
and all the GMOs that's not good for us but the sad thing is we're actually changing our genetic
makeup that even if we could magically make all that stuff disappear tomorrow we've done damage to
genetic makeup that we can't but do and we're passing that on to the next generation and we can't change
that for the better. So we're more important to make these epigenetic changes, be it these lifestyle
changes now as much as you possibly can. And I feel like I just know that half the people listening
and be like how do I work with you right now? Do we have to be in Minnesota to work with you or
can we work with you online? What kind of programs do you have for us? So with our cancer patients
probably 80% of them are not in the five state area around Minnesota. So we see patients from all over
the world, many of them come to us. We have programs that we actually travel to them within the United
States. So we have practitioners in our office that will be out sometimes every week in another part
of the country. There's patients that just can't travel for their health reasons or don't like
to travel. As far as non-cancer patients doing genetic work and doing functional medicine work,
almost all of that is over the internet, over the phone, distant type work, online work, even if the
person is local. So it's just an advantage that we have now with the internet that we can get
on the phone with somebody. Do a Zoom call, see them face-to-face and work through their issues.
So the black kids that we need do the genetic workup that we need. So they don't have to be local.
It's everything is online. Amazing. I'm so grateful for that. That's absolutely wonderful. So they
just need to go to cornersclinic.com to start to work with you right away and set up that initial call.
Yeah, they could do that. And they have trade nutritionists and
nutritionetic practitioners that work for me and know that all your cases go through me as well.
So they're working with somebody and they're stuck on something. They come in my office and we work
through it what's going to be the best for that patient. So just call the office, contact the office,
there's contact form all over our website as well. We'll get back to you and we can set up that
initial consultation with either myself or one of our nutritionists and work it with our nutritionists
is extremely affordable. So amazing. Well, thank you. And so if you're listening right now and you
or a loved one, you know, needs this right now, go to cornersclinic.com. And before we wrap up,
Dr. Connors, can you tell us a little bit about your books and who they're for and who should be
reading them? So I wrote the books that I did write for people that would never be able to come to me.
So I just thought, well, I just got to, I feel like we come from a Christian perspective in our
office and we feel like, well, you've been given much. You have to give back much. So we tried to
again, like I said previously, teach as much as possible sides I like to teach. So books are for anybody.
So you can get them on Amazon if you like a hard copy to read. We have them all available as the
download, like most of them are free download as well. And those are on our website. Even if you
don't work with us, you could take some of that information and talk to your local doctor and work
through some of those things as well. And we just want to be a blessing to people. That's ultimately
the bottom line. What a beautiful goal and mission. And I'm so grateful for what you do. And I'm so glad
you came on today and really broke these things down. And I look forward to talking to you again.
I know there's many more things that we could get into. But I really appreciate you being here today.
Well, thanks so much, Ellie. Thank you for all you do. You're just a blessing to everybody.
Well, thank you. Back at ya.